so just introduce myself my name is Noel
George nd somewhere and so I started
last May
yes I'm glad we finally connected I'm
sorry it took so long tell me about
yourself
sure so I was born and raised in New
York so I went to CL University I
graduated last year with my master's
degree in marketing and I also want
their undergraduate as well as marketing
in psychology it's awesome what can I
answer for you so can you find me Marcus
because that was so structured yeah I
mean honestly don't beat yourself up you
landed in the right place yeah we're not
gonna beat you up right so I think
you're beating yourself up you're 5
seconds out I know you don't but you
don't think you can't not know I just
don't know how right you've got to get
out of that rhythm yeah you got to get
into real life with them yeah well
you're a kid you're a kid don't beat
yourself up if it's not coming easy yet
you have to decompose from that old
environment yeah and then try to do a
couple things that feel uncomfortable
it's always stretching yourself
yeah I have a lot of interest but I'm
like I don't know I could get into that
I know how to get it I don't know right
step sure people talk to you and always
constantly like doing it and then like
pulling back and then wanting to put off
my wall here and I do that I'm just
it's obviously yeah I think you need to
deploy some patience yeah that's all
yeah I'm sure you have plenty of
missions I'm sure you have things you
want to prove to yourself and to others
we all do but patience is the absolute
secret sauce to all of this yeah that's
that's definitely the hardest part I
always been say like yeah you always
have like oh project three months you're
done like you did great
hey and then now it's like okay now it's
like you always say it's like a long
game it's like all right when do you
find see the fruits it's really more
like come out and you never know like
when it'll happen like yeah and it's
like so the fruit to your labor a fruits
of your labor conversation at 23 to me
is ludicrous yeah you know I get it but
but I want to get you out of it yeah I
know I was 34 years old when I left my
dad's liquor store and like had nothing
I built my dad's liquor store for him
like didn't make that much money
like and was just starting at 34 do you
feel pressure from anybody outside
yourself if you're being honest
well yeah but outside right now
not really it really comes from within
yeah yeah I mean look I think that's
right I think if you can just figure out
if if you're being competitive with your
circle of friends or things of that
nature and the competition whatever it
could be around that super important for
you to understand it because once you
get like it's incredibly empowering and
happy once you can calibrate all this by
trusting the process and always auditing
if you're complacent or being patient
right yeah but to me you're probably not
if you're having this level of complex
like you know what I would what advice I
would get listen I don't know enough yet
but like intuitively right now in this
limited time I feel like literally
making a rule that you can't think about
anything other than like
one day at a time having fun learning
being young for the next 24 months like
not allowed that like you have to you
could you can after we tear 25th
birthday to even start debating what's
happening here would be monumentally
impactful on you so you understand you
could do nothing right for the next
seven years start putting it together on
your 30th birthday and still have plenty
of time to achieve everything I get it
yeah it's you know what's scary it's
true the fact that you even thinking
about getting it or not gettin it is the
problem 25 no judging no debating know
even pondering if this is good bad
getting you to where you need to or not
ha I'm being serious with you I think
that gets you to where you want to get
to way faster than debating it in the
short term you need to take a little
steam out of the engine and take a
breath a little bit it will help you
it'll get a lot more quiet which will
create a lot more room so what do you
think from that so obviously we grow in
the department you're gonna learn about
something that has influence in culture
III think influencer marketing is one of
the best departments to be in that
Vayner I think we are figuring out how
to like navigate it right now it's still
in a limbo stage but I think you're
gonna learn I think again I think your
natural planning DNA I think you're
trying to make a game plan and attack
you're trying to attack and I'm trying
to have you be more karate which is take
the force that comes at you and adjust
with it and I think influencer marketing
is a really good thing which is nobody
really knows where it goes but learning
it is gonna be highly valuable for you
going forward yeah how how it works is a
media function how it works
cultural function how humans interact
look I think you need to calibrate your
ambition / insecurity whatever it is 100
and zero fifty-fifty you put your you
need to take that pressure out of the
system it will work for you you make a
commitment like if you sleep on this and
come back and email me and say I'm doing
it and say I'm literally not gonna judge
myself one way or the other for the next
22 months until I'm 25 I think it really
really impact you in a positive way I
really believe that I'm being serious
yeah you deserve it now you're now
you're in control oh you're still
latching on to those behaviors yeah you
got to fix that it's awesome you're
welcome have a great day my pleasure
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]